I'm a normal guy a simple guy but I'm
going to change the world I lost my wife
and I spy with a low with four children
no money the only thing I found relieve
it with in cold water and reading it
said I'm a messenger by the way I'm a
man on a mission now I don't stop until
we have no war anymore no disease no
depression yeah what's up elimination I
am at the Evergreen Rick works here in
Toronto Canada I'm about to go do wimp
hop hold a seminar on breathing and ice
bath I'm excited and I'm nervous for it
we're going to hopefully have a chance
to talk to women I learn about his story
it's May 20th when I'm recording this my
birthday and so we're going to see what
wim has to offer and hopefully have fun
in the cold bad
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we are ready for a great day
that's the iSchool Wow
just get going then take it everyone I
love it
[Music]
yes yeah that might get a good story we
live in a world where there's all kinds
of false healers and fake alternative
medicine programs you can sign up for
it's a rare moment in history when
someone comes along who can perform real
miracles with real evidence to back them
up wim HOF has defied logic time and
time again and always under scientific
scrutiny
he holds the world record for being able
to be submerged in ice for almost two
hours without his core body temperature
changing he's climbed Mount Everest in
nothing but a pair of shorts and ran a
marathon in the desert without drinking
any water
he's even proven in a laboratory setting
that he can withstand illnesses using
the power of his mind but he's not a
freak of nature according to win anyone
can do what he can do they just have to
learn his method the wim HOF method
using a combination of cold immersion
breathing techniques and mental focus
anyone can accomplish feats that were
previously thought to be impossible so
before getting into it I want it I want
to tell you how I found you so I used to
always get sick always I always I always
believed that if you were sick don't
come close to me because I'm going to
get sick so on my team of people were
sick like stay home they'll come to me
again I get sick then in January I got
really really sick five days
just straight hiccups constantly hiccups
hiccups and then I decided I'm never
gonna get sick again I just figure out a
way never to get sick and then I
stumbled across your work what you're
doing said I'm going to give it a shot
and since then I haven't gotten sick
January all right now back to a tomato
way to go way to go way to go thank you
[Music]
[Music]
explain the mission why are you doing
this why it's important to you it's not
just about setting the world record so
what do you do this yes as I said and a
lot of stuff outside in nature because I
felt this disconnection from nature
inside from soul itself soul is not able
to express and you can see it in the
world full of depression and autoimmune
diseases cancer older stink and anxiety
so nobody knows actually is because of
the disconnection of nature so resulted
in me in an awkward feeling I don't know
what there is but there is more than
meets the eye
we're going to show all those the native
spirits have to subdue a couple of
hundred years here now they are coming
back through us through the love making
sense that the mother nature is very I'm
going into a soul search and that
brought me to all kinds of traditions as
a terror disciplines languages religions
debates about philosophy cultures
anything you know but in the end it
didn't connect with me that's what the
cold water came in I the cold water is
merciless but right so bum now you got
to be there right but little by little
you begin to wake up to that what you
feel inside it's beginning to wake up a
real primordial disconnection is
beginning to connect to your
consciousness brain-body connection
there is in the books if what's not
there
and now we changed the book the
University and Hall of the story began
just [ __ ] freezing water that's after
a lot of esoteric disciplines
philosophies traditions languages
religion doctrines yoga on food anything
I could get my hands upon and do it I
did but that it could not bring that
connection which I was looking for I
wanted to know the purpose of the soul
so so I went
finally the in conflict with nature and
i found this rectitude actually the very
aggressive impact on you but i tell just
people collected and i got in Tidewater
because agree their health without words
this is it
the first time I went under the water is
as sharp as needles I saw this as a big
huge shop diamond
at 35 meters I lost sight because the
retina explodes I couldn't see nothing I
couldn't breathe of course
and then my consciousness succumbed to a
lower consciousness this is survival so
the story begins with a feeling and I
want you to feel with me
so let's breathe then Julian don't ask
yourself how just always use any hole
you got get it in I let it go I just
wanna press your head take a bullet hole
and swim with me swim come on move yours
[Music]
the Hulu mother nature moving into a
[Music]
rebirth will bring the deepest within
ourselves
I do not fear death I fear not to live
fully if I left early and nothing to
that I'm living
[Music]
singing I lost over there the fear of
death and this whereas I found it the
fear of death no longer and that made me
able to do very strange stuff like
climbing Mount Everest he chose to death
though LeMans our own rocket I'm
swimming under the ice standing for
2,000 years hanging by one finger in the
midwinter one mile climbing all kinds of
mountains barefoot in the snow staying
outside a whole night in freezing
temperatures and nothing but shorts
because you learn to deal with the
elements of nature and then you find out
that the inner power of the physiology
both through the brain a body connection
is so much more than we ever thought
possible
it's about confronting yourself with
coal the coal is a natural element able
to bring you right down to the core the
depth of the mystery yourself called
life loving it
so there I was Mount Everest he was
about seven thousand sixty meters in
there I was sitting around but they are
the one the middle of it I didn't know
where what expounded so much Peter
I was lost a lot but not lost in time
this connection I felt like until the
paranoid or anxiety until today it's
where I found has found nothing the
books once again confidence and belief
is really opened me up I could try again
under birth I just had a good time for
the rest of the days I were there and
now after doing 26 of those world
records about numerous more challenges
got me a got me in contact with
scientists and then it came about that I
was awakening as stimulating an
influencing system within the body they
thought of not being able to be
influenced or connected with for humans
they thought and humans can alter it's
happening it's an autonomic nervous
system with autonomy care process
outside of our world but brain body can
actually remember connection there it is
and now I'm able to connect enter and
make a difference and that's what I did
in this study
Wims mission is to use his body as a
laboratory to revolutionize our
understanding of physiology in 2011 he
was injected with the bacterial
endotoxin in an experiment that
challenged our understanding of the
nervous
in normal humans the injection should
cause a strong immune response leading
to fever chills and headaches but not
and when it appeared that he was somehow
able to suppress his immune response by
making his body secrete adrenaline
suggesting that his method can allow us
to influence our immune system at will
scientists thought he might just be a
freak of nature so to further prove this
theory they perform the same experiment
on 12 subjects women trained in Poland
and the same thing happened who only get
after competitive study with groups so I
took on a full group I trained him for
days to get into the autonomic nervous
system and all those things and they got
a administered with the bacteria and as
well all within a quarter of our
entering in the into those systems and
now we are getting somewhere how the
mind yes we are dealing in modern day
society you can go to the moon we can go
to Mars and everywhere but we cannot
check into the death of ourselves and
make the difference with either
depression anxiety is trauma PTSD and
we don't control our life you're not
able to embrace it how divine well
there's - ongoing don't blow it
doesn't let us feel completely it is
there all the time
now we turn the wheel normally it's very
difficult to increase your adrenaline
levels by your own will adrenaline is
released by the autonomic nervous system
and autonomic means that you cannot
voluntarily influence it so if you walk
outside and you are wrapped on the
street you will have a heart rate of 160
and your blood pressure will be sky-high
within seconds but if I ask you now to
increase your heart rate you cannot do
it you cannot so entirely modulate that
and with the techniques of wim HOF we
show that we was able to increase his
adrenaline that was very high
concentrations even higher than people
that go bungee jumping for the first
time they saw him doing all kinds of
strange stuff because what I was doing
but not possible by the physiology and I
did it not given a shock and they gave
it a shine so there are lost approval
and then I go visit an amazing one
everybody is able to do this everybody
is able to do this what and how much
training these people need a year a year
or in fact before they are able to do a
little bit what you are able to do what
you showed I had attended just sugar
that like a 7 it only became fully and
these guys are chuh to my place and
ponent in the mountains the shadow side
it's recall that out their heart
they fought without prior experience
with hope they were able to go in shoes
optimally - them to begin with up to be
top - 27 and then we did the the Harlem
shake
so I knew that these guys already they
got the mindset they got the wage hmm -
BC - 47 that's alpha now that's you that
your power into it we aligned that your
mind be able to believe you're able to
conquer by connection the way mother
nature meant it to be inside with about
any system we go now people who suffer
from depression anxiety fear from all
those a PTSD trauma they they are living
under template comes instruct and they
are not able to break the loop now I
showed how to break the loop I'm a
messenger by the way I'm a man on a
mission I don't stop until we have no
war anymore no disease no depression to
promote sound yeah for the people who
are coming down people coming for the
people watching this video what's what's
the message you hope that they take away
I'm experiencing some wim Hof's today in
size and confidence that we are very
capable of bringing back the inner power
realized to become a be strong and
healthy
far more than ever before thought
possible so that's it feeling is
understanding so once this sense gets to
the minds then it's going to open up
this thing called hope and that hope
this time is going to pay off it's just
a matter of a little practice then I'm
going to show how to change the
chemistry inside and then to battle one
of the most severe aggressive impacts on
the body ice cold water and feel well
and not only feel well feel a little bit
depressed because there is no barfing
doc inside I have a job all right I'm
looking forward to thank you for the
time and looking put to the session oh
cool cool cool cool it again
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
we move the hand to make a surfable use
the boys like they using your buck you
karate
you know in the nation yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah girl
well for you oh dear
last year what okay nice not going okay
let's begin let's start breathing lie
down sit down stand on your head doesn't
matter what you do just to relax your
body
whoo yes belly cast eat your head and
let it go well Jeff had letting it go
not feeling as simple as today we love
too much neurology going on
we think we think data but yes there is
nothing more than life itself
because it is happening anyway there we
go Julian let it go
you become lightheaded Lucy the body
English it's all alright heading in
letting go without death and even into
your head you're able to store up oxygen
and letting it go here comes the last
one fooling we're letting go after the
exhalation stop
[Music]
when you feel the urge to breathe it's
no competition you take them in fully
let's do it all boolean Oh tell second
and squeeze it push it to the head to
bring in more oxygen in the brain stem
five four three two one as a real
ethical okay really excited to that they
call it power breathing fully breathe
come on will ya go for ya know Lou Lou
Lou Lou Lou yo Paulie go for ya go for
ya go ahh
Oh three two one
luli Oh luli art and how boolean and
block contract activist just yet now
your head squeeze three two one let it
go we got to do a push-up exercise for
those for those for those who have a
planetory condition like a triennial or
a mess or anything like that to be
chromed anything if you do it after
inhalation who shops after Emily brings
down the predatory marketers ooh this
one brings you research you in four
minutes
so four minutes exercise you can do it
any time of the day
oh yes there you go Julie Larry Oh Julia
Larry go three two one Erika's boolean
letting go
stop a vaccination huijeong no breathing
just go down yourself this is what I do
the people who could not even do one who
jobs totally be able to do 20 amazing
[Music]
this is the budget and that's you that's
you guys good luck
[Applause]
you know we can slide our devices okay
so we have to go first
we're not come back for lunch because
horseback who else to do so we could be
some new friend join yourselves and
we'll let you draw whether instruct the
second half okay grand or cool so that
was pretty epic guys I've never had a
lot of success meditating is actually
something I can claim the boat or just
was worried about never got a good
chance meditator and never felt it but
this for the first time I was in a
different zone my fingers are still
tingling I'm doing it and I've been
practicing that home but never to that
extent so I got a really good I got a
really good tool the speech was awesome
but but just the last however long that
was I kind of spaced out was worth the
price of admission and so I'm really
pumped to get in the water was kind of
doubting but after that I'm feeling
pretty good and also continuing to have
it so we're going to have some lunch and
then get back to it
[Music]
[Music]
I'm a solo goddess imple data but I'm
going to change the world I lost my wife
a nice I was alone with four children no
money the only thing I found relieving
with in cold water and breathing inside
just a hunch
and I did it just to reconnect with
their point I use your mind become happy
strong and healthy and those are the
most essential in life then the rest
will help you just think about it let's
see if you come up with any difficulty
or this or that no from now on if you
are able to tackle it then you're
totally doing these crazy video views
this is that it is not saying he is not
okay and you don't believe it now sign
what what did the difference just keep
at it keep on believing that has to
distract it out is natural instead of
cancer and autoimmune diseases and
depression and that thinking that that
is Noble I think it is sick and it
should not be here with us no longer
from here we passed with we become
saying strong Navi and rest out of the
way
we're below not inside as God that love
each other that love yeah so I I can see
that with my eye yeah a nap during the
Lord then I love ice cream mg ah never
been opening Chuck oh it's a recipe in
English oh well the ice is melting
normally I work laying okay okay okay
let's go up and that everybody okay you
know we are going to the ISIS like you
you said around this loop and II just
follow the breath get away
now you sit down you later
up till tonight put your hands on the
side right to induce the wall and that
relax control
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
car 1 plus 4 plus more okay good so yes
I can sort of a thank you on 12 and
everyone
go [ __ ] yourself goodbye takes a lot of
water so we are done it is what happened
is five o'clock course the dogs are you
been an all-day thing they clean up
pretty quickly
what did you what did you take away from
this what did you learn I learned that
I'm stronger than I think yeah high five
for that
good job meaning I will never imagine
myself you sit in that cold bath ice
bath for that long so now now when the
air conditionings on at night we're
going to sleep so yeah that's nothing we
should turn the air conditioning up even
higher
I know blowing on this day but you look
what you just sat in ice water
I like a colder room than even though I
had a really good time I met a lot of
fans here which is good talk about a
dozen different fans some from
entrepreneurial content and also some
people watched the two other videos we
did on win and his techniques some
people attend number of people said that
the first movie that we did that has a
million views now was their first
introduction to wim and the reason why
they came here so that was really cool
really cool to see lots of fun people
lots of good wisdom we're going to
breathe we're going to breathe daily
yeah we're going to breathe daily thank
you promise we're going to have our
morning rituals to Incline involve the
breathing yeah okay good well thank you
guys for watching hope you enjoyed our
journey with us and go check out the
Lamaze method I highly recommend it and
attorney allowed me not to be sick for
almost six months
and looking forward to what happens now
that Nina and I are going to do it
together a good couple therapy to thank
you guys for watching continue to
believe you can say we believe in you
how are we believing you and continue to
believe for see you soon and whatever
and whenever you want where is much love
we'll see you soon
you